so you may notice that I no longer have
the stubble scruff call it whatever you
want on my face a lot of people saying I
should keep the scruff some people
saying I should get rid of it a lot of
people completely unaffected by what
hair is on my face because they care
about news and politics but as you as
you may know I sort of been into the
metal safety razors lately and we've
reviewed a bunch of them that different
viewers of the show have sent me uh but
I really haven't been actually doing the
clean shave lately because I basically
cut myself every single time my bathroom
looks like I've either been cooking beet
soup or may have killed someone after
i'm done shaving usually uh but
mavericks which is a Silicon Valley
skincare company sent me their shave gel
to try and I said well uh my stubble
scruff whatever is uh getting a little
tired so why don't I actually try
shaving with this stuff and I have to
tell you it was fantastic uh I I think
the best analogy I can think of is like
ice skating on freshly Zambo need ice as
I ran my safety razor over my skin I did
not cut myself it was incredibly smooth
uh and it is a shaving moisturizer that
they sent me so i guess the sort of make
sense but it was a fantastic shaving
experience i must say and i may be back
on the clean-shaven look although we do
have this upcoming vacation and my thing
is usually not to even take any shaving
supplies during the entire vacation but
until then I I think I'm back on the
clean-shaven look because the experience
with the Mavericks gel was great so
check it out go to get Mavericks dot-com
you can also use the link in the video
description I loved it I think you will
too